I mean are people normally doing like
face cream and stuff like that is this
really heavy
hey I'm Jeremy Strong
they do a thing called 10 essential
items I've clearly broken that
assignment there's more than 10 things
here these are all very important
artifacts from my life that I'm sharing
with you
[Music]
this is from season two this is a letter
that I ripped up at a press conference
if you've seen the show you probably
know what that moment was
oh this is from season one this is
Kendall I don't know if you can see it
this was on my suit after I had gone
into the water at the end of season one
at my sister's wedding that was a really
harrowing difficult thing to do but this
is the only thing I've kept from that
from That season
this I love as you can see I sort of
already have my own version of it I
wanted something for Kendall's birthday
in season three that felt colossal
Rasheed Johnson is an artist that I've
admired and I saw that he had
collaborated with Liz swigg based on a
series of paintings that he made called
the anxious man paintings would this was
like a keystone that made everything
come together for me
this is also from my birthday party I
seem to make a drink stirrer with my
face on it like 3D printed with a crown
so
they did
the end of season three we're in Italy
and every time you do a movie or every
time I do a season of this there's
always a scene that you read that you
think
I can't do I can't do this and I don't
know how I'm gonna do this and I just
remember being in that sort of trance in
this room
before we shot that scene and the
feeling of peril this was on the door in
that room and and and I guess I looked
at it because part of what you have to
do as an actor is get out of your way
and so I looked at it and it was kind of
just telling me something about don't
disturb like yourself and surrender to
the uncertainty and the unknown but that
was a tough day you know the scene
didn't go well for like nine or ten
takes and then on the next take I sat
down on the ground which I hadn't done
before and that's what's in the show and
that's but that was just a result of
giving up and sort of coming face to
face with my own in a sense uh limits
this is pretty self-explanatory this is
a script binder that Robert Duvalle gave
me so it's just something that I
treasure I went down to visit him once
at his farm in Virginia and he's got the
Godfather scripts in one of these the
same same binders same company same
stenciling and everything I find this
object both a very meaningful given who
it came from you know I've learned a lot
from him I think he's one of the
greatest actors of all time but what's
scary about holding this right now is
that it is really just at this point the
exoskeleton that is going to contain
something that I don't know what that
thing will be next so it's it's sort of
a steadying and comforting and
reinforcing to have this kind of
embracing it and then the thing on the
inside will be I guess the next risk and
attempt at doing something
Jacques marimage
sunglasses the best company making
sunglasses right now jeromege a
Frenchman who lives in L.A I have been
very deliberate about candle sunglasses
and I've worn some of his frames last
year and I kind of sent up a flare and
reached out to him and asked him if we
could collaborate on something for this
season so he his frames are made in
Japan and and he went there and I
pitched him sort of the colorway that I
liked and this old model that they
didn't make anymore he made me
well he made Kendall
these sunglasses
and Kendall's initials Kendall Logan Roy
KLR are written on the inside
I have my pair which also say KLR and
Kendall's pair
so I do know where one ends and where
the other begins
[Music]
so I've never shown this to anyone this
is sat on my desk for like over 20 years
these are like artifacts from work I've
done since my early 20s this cup was
from a play that I did called a matter
of choice in a storefront on 39th Street
and I guess I'll just
kind of dump some stuff out this is a
cherry bomb from The Trial of Chicago
seven I lit as Jerry Rubin in a scene
demonstrating how to make a cherry bomb
to to the students in a class
this is a watch that I wore in the first
movie I ever did called Humboldt County
wow I mean I haven't touched these
things in a long time
that's from Molly's game I used to be
able to do all kinds of Poker tricks but
I can't anymore you forget you know you
when you do these things you fill
yourself up with all kinds of visceral
understanding but also whatever skills
you need to do it but they leave you
when it's done I don't even know what
this is
double smearing off rocks
this is when Kendall goes off the wagon
in Arizona from the end of the first
season I called a friend of mine who was
recently sober and I said what would you
order if if you were going to go off the
wagon and so this is from this bar in
Arizona
first play I did Off-Broadway play
called Defiance by John Patrick Shanley
I played a marine there was a letter
written by a soldier who was in Vietnam
that he wrote home to his parents and he
ended the letter saying we are all in
desperate need of love
so that's what this says on here
a story about The Velveteen Rabbit that
I was going to tell to my kids on
succession that we that we shot that
didn't make it into the show just an
improvised story that I asked Jesse if I
could do
this is from a Eugene O'Neill play
called Huey that I'd seen pachino do I
tried to do myself when I was an
undergrad in college and so I did I did
that play and this is probably the
oldest thing I have I did this maybe
when I was 19.
Vinnie Daniels character I played in The
Big Short this is all I kept from it you
know there's a Stanley Kunitz poem
called the layers and he says I have
walked through many lives some of them
my own so these feel like fragments of
lives that I've walked through and this
is all that's left of any of them really
I mean the truth is these are such a big
part of your life and there's a strange
finality when they're over they're just
over I know they might exist on
Celluloid or on TV but I don't go back
and watch anything and so I guess I keep
little artifacts you know I mean this is
the first time I've ever taken them out
so I'm not sure to what end but they do
kind of take me back to different selves
that I've walked through
[Music]
this is a record of Glenn Gould's
recording First Recording he did two
recordings of The Goldberg Variations by
Bach it's a piece of music that I've
Loved for my adult life I listen to it
all the time Glenn Gould was a really
eccentric individual and he broke all
the rules about what was considered
appropriate kinds of concert pianist
protocol he would hum exclaim and make
sounds while he was playing and he said
something that I wrote down that I think
about sometimes he said that the purpose
of art is not a momentary ejection of
adrenaline but rather the lifelong
construction of a state of Wonder and
serenity
so that's what I think about when I
think about Glenn Gould his piano
playing is beautiful and incomparable
and ecstatic and probably would be the
piece of music I'd want to listen to if
I am lucky enough to choose the piece of
music I want to listen to at the end I
use Music a lot depending on the
emotional valence of a scene music can
help me enter into a deeper place in
myself that I might need to come from so
music is at access point for me
foreign
[Music]
delgadio is an incredible artist
Illusionist magician who had a one-man
show called in and of itself they turned
it into a film it's on Hulu I urge
everyone to watch it because it's one of
the more astonishing things I've ever
seen when you go into the show you pick
out a card from a wall I am something
something that is feels self-identifying
at the end of the show he tells each
person the hundreds of people in the
audience what card they picked the
rulatista is a central character in the
story that he tells who is essentially
someone who played Russian Roulette to
great success and was willing to risk
everything every time and exist on that
precipice of danger Derek in the show
talks about himself being the realtista
and he sent this to me he said that he'd
not sent this to anyone else but he sent
this card to me so it was profoundly
meaningful to me rilka said that surely
all great artists the product of having
been in danger this is a person who is
willing to endanger himself again and
again and again and again
foreign
this is a book of paintings
by Howard Hodgkin who was a famous
British painter incredible painter I was
in London and I was working and I walked
into the National Portrait Gallery and
there was an exhibition of this guy's
work and I hadn't heard of him
what he does is he sort of takes moments
in time that were profound moments for
him or moments that really struck him in
a certain way and then he tries to
translate those moments pictorially so
he's painting the feeling of moments in
time he would also paint over the frame
of his paintings behind the Hedge
I find them just incredibly moving
simple deep moving
as an actor that's your palette as well
your palette is your own experiences and
memories and feelings that you try to
bring in an abstract way using someone
else's words you float those words on
top of an undercurrent of feeling and so
something about these paintings
just resonated with me
foreign
I mean this is like a five hour
conversation right here so I'm not
really sure these are all books that
have been really important books to me
Alma mahlers Diaries
composer herself
married to Klimt and Mahler who talks
about the dichotomy inside people of
what she calls the loving soul and the
calculating soul and her belief was
these creators that were in her life
these great creators of the 20th century
made work of real value when they were
operating from the loving soul rather
than the calculating Soul it's a great
book
spectator bird Wallace stegner takes
place in Denmark which is a place that I
now live but I read this before it I
even knew where it was on a map I think
he talks about
the pain in every choice when we're
younger we're in this life of sort of
infinite possibility but I think to
become an adult is to collapse choices
to make choices and to lose that sense
of infinite possibility
Robert Johnson this is sort of jungian
dream work stuff about the Shadow the
part of ourselves that we've disavowed
but is still there always there that's a
big part of Kendall that's been a lot of
the subtext of the show
my favorite play uh the caretaker by
Harold Pinter
Incredible Book on acting probably the
if I could pick one book on acting for
if a young actor was like what should I
read I would say this book
John cabotzin he is a remarkable man who
is a mindfulness teacher MIT trained
scientist he created something called
mindfulness-based stress reduction I've
gone on some Retreats silent Retreats
with him four quartets by T.S Eliot when
I was 18 went to the Royal Academy of
dramatic art the principal told us all
to go out and get this book he said it's
the only thing you ever need to know
about acting I kind of agree there's a
line in here about a condition of
complete Simplicity costing not less
than everything
um
I've already quoted this dude
Bruce In Search of Lost time you know I
spent a couple years in my early 20s
like working in room service and waiting
tables and these books kind of saved me
because I would you know I didn't have
much of a social life I didn't have any
money there's so much of what anyone
would hope to learn about life contained
in these volumes
and then number one for me is my
struggle uh by Carl Knaus guard
Norwegian writer contemporary Norwegian
writer it's the most honest expression
of life that I've ever read anywhere he
writes in this incredibly granular way
he'll spend 40 pages talking about
taking his four-year-old daughter like
to a party and the shoes that she wants
to wear and the effect of it the
accumulative effect of it by being in
such granular detail of life is you see
the Beauty and the sacredness in in
those small moments and you realize that
there are no small moments that's my
fast version of these books
[Music]